le des grands films en sait maintenant
non c'est pas maintenant mais c'est
bientôt c'est dans combien de lodosa
c'est donc pas beaucoup de dodo le 11
mai maintenant alors comment ça va se
passer
on sait à peu près est-ce que ça va bien
se passer
combien de temps ça va durer est ce
qu'on va se confirmer on ne sait pas qui
on s'est un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
bon voilà cette fois on y est on savait
déjà quand on va sortir maintenant on
sait à peu près comment on va sortir
enfin on va sortir le 11 mai sauf si le
nombre de cas de malades en réanimation
par exemple se remet à augmenter si on
fait les comptes en fait normes et
disons que tout va bien se passer est
qu'on va bien ceux des confits né le 11
mai alors plutôt que de refaire le tour
de tout ce qui a été annoncé
maintenant vous êtes au courant même
s'il ya ce pas mal de questions mais
tout ça ça va venir
on va plutôt s'intéresser à un truc qui
fait flipper un petit peu tout le monde
le risque d'une
alors est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
deuxième vague est ce que la question
c'est pas plutôt quelle taille avait à
faire
parce que le virus dit toujours là on
n'a pas de traitement
on a pas de vaccin on va tous ressortir
de chez nous à priori on serait à peu
près 6 % avoir été infectés alors qu'il
faudrait qu'on soit au moins 70% à être
immunisé pour pouvoir compter sur
l'immunité collective et encore
l'immunité
on est deux moins en moins sûr mais ça
ah bon on va reparler après le conseil
scientifique celui qui conseille le
gouvernement dans la crise actuelle
il estime qu'avec le confinement on a
réduit le taux de transmission du virus
2 70% donc c'est énorme mais là le
confinement on va lever progressivement
donc ça va être forcément moins save que
si on était tous rester chez nous alors
attention ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas des consignes et on va pas rester
enfermé comme ça en attendant que ça
passe on sait même pas quand ça a passé
donc il faut y aller à un moment ou un
autre parce qu'en vrai là actuellement
grâce au confinement l'épidémie ont la
maîtrise à peu près le but serait de
continuer à avoir le contrôle sur le
nombre de cas pour que au pire on est
quittes vaguelettes avec le
déconfinement mais pas sous la main en
fait l'objectif ça va resté le même à
savoir protéger les personnes les plus
fragiles évidemment pour éviter d'avoir
des décès et puis limiter au maximum le
nombre de personnes hospitalisées
notamment en réanimation parce que en
réanimation dans le nombre de places est
limité
ça demande du matériel et du personnel
qualifiés donc il essaie de pas saturer
le système hospitalier pour pas qu'il
explose parce qu'il faut pas oublier que
si les hôpitaux sont saturés
il n'y a pas que les gens qui ont le
kobe de 19 qui pourront pas de soigner
il ya tous les autres aussi ceux qui
font moins un infarctus qui font un avc
ceux qui ont un accident de la route
donc le virus il menace même la vie de
gens qui l'ont pas potentiellement et
puis faut pas oublier un truc le
personnel soignant savez les gens que
vous applaudissez à dauphine est le soir
ils vont pas tenir comme ça encore
longtemps un moment il va falloir qu'ils
se reposent là ils ont fait des efforts
de dingue pour contrôler l'épidémie est
un moment il va falloir que ça se calme
alors du coup comment est ce qu'on va
faire pour que ça se calme et puis
surtout est ce que on va
arrivant à vue il ya d'abord le cas des
personnes fragiles des personnes à
risque
là le gouvernement a fait le choix de
leur faire confiance d'appeler à la
responsabilité individuelle c'est à dire
que dans l'absolu l'idée c'est que les
personnes à risque continuent à rester
confinés comme on l'est tous depuis
plusieurs semaines mais il va y avoir
d'obligation la paille hors de contrôle
donc c est à chacun de se discipliner et
de se responsabiliser à ce niveau là et
après pour limiter le nombre de nouveaux
cas ben il ya plusieurs scénarios
envisageables soit avec les mesures qui
ont été mises en place on arrive à
maîtriser le nombre de cas qu'on arrive
à préserver le système hospitalier
le nombre de cas il va continuer à
diminuer
on va lever progressivement les mesures
de protection et l'épidémie elle va
finir par s'éteindre scénario optimiste
soit on n'arrive pas du tout à maîtriser
le nombre de nouveaux cas il ya de
nouveau un gros risque de saturation des
hôpitaux et bim c'est reparti pour le
grand confinement scénario pessimiste là
soit on arrive plus ou moins à contrôler
le nombre de nouveaux cas mais quand
même il ya des moments où ça devient un
petit peu chaud donc on alterne les
périodes de confinement et les périodes
d confinés jusqu'à ce que ça se tasse
scénario qui fait pas plaisir mais quand
même c'est mieux que si c'était pire
et puis après il sera temps de se poser
la question à savoir est-ce que ce virus
il a disparu complètement
ou est-ce qu'il va revenir tous les ans
comme la grippe par exemple parce que ça
va devenir une épidémie saisonnière va
pas se prendre la tête avec ça
maintenant tout de suite mais il faut
savoir qu'il ya des scientifiques qui
commencent à se poser la question
spoiler ils ont pas encore la réponse
donc à chaque jour suffit sa peine
bon alors donc comment est ce qu'on va
faire ça comment est ce qu'on va essayer
de contrôler et de maîtriser le nombre
de nouveaux cas pendant un moment on a
cru qu'on allait pouvoir compter sur
l'immunité collective dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure l'immunité collective en
gros c'est quand le pourcentage de
personnes qui sont immunisés contre le
virus est suffisant pour empêcher la
maladie de se propager
parce que un malade il a croisé trop de
gens protéger donc il va contaminer à
cette gens pour que l'épidémie s'étende
en gros ça fait baisser le taux de
reproduction de base de la maladie le
fameux air 0 je sais pas si vous en avez
déjà entendu parler on schématise et ça
correspond au nombre de personnes qu'un
malade va infecter en moyenne plus la
maladie est contagieuse plus le nombre
est élevé là en temps normal que 8,19
c'est 3,3 c'est à dire que on estime
qu'en moyenne un malade va contaminer un
peu plus de trois personnes et avec le
confinement il a chuté à 0.5
quand même pas mal et pour continuer à
maîtriser l'épidémie foxer 0 il reste en
dessous de 1
on pourrait dès confinés comme ça sans
prendre aucune mesure si on était 70% à
être immunisé et le problème c'est que
le 11 mai comme on a dit tout à l'heure
on sera maximum 6 % de la population à
avoir été infectés par le virus infecte
et pas forcément immunisés parce que au
niveau de l'immunité on n'est plus sûr
de rien ça c'est un problème les
questions qui se posent c'est en gros
est ce que avoir été infectés ça suffit
pour être immunisé est-ce que les
anticorps qu'on développe
ils sont systématiquement efficace et
puis s'ils sont efficaces
combien de temps ils sont efficaces en
gros la réponse à toutes ces questions
c'est qu'on n'est pas sûr qu'on sait pas
trop donc autant vous dire que pour
l'immunité collective on va pouvoir
laisser tomber le seul moyen d'avoir une
immunité collective la actuellement ce
serait d'avoir un vaccin mais un vaccin
on en a pas et on n'est pas près d'en
avoir alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour garder ce fameux air
haut en dessous des 1 on fait comment
alors qu'on va ressortir de chez nous
qu'on va retourner bosser qu'on va
retourner en cour que les magasins vont
rouvrir qu'on va se recroiser toute la
journée et qu'on va prendre les
transports etc
déjà on va tous porter des masques
finalement alors on va tous porter des
masques quand les mesures de
distanciation physique seront
impossibles
l'adie de edouard philippe je sens bien
convenir que au moins au début on va les
mettre tout le temps par sécurité
alors le problème avec les masques c'est
que la façon dont ça a été géré depuis
le début la communication et tout le
reste n'a pas été fait de façon
extrêmement clean pour dire les choses
poliment entre eux les discours pas
clair les recommandations médicales est
les résultats d'études qui ont été un
petit peu utilisé de façon à faire
oublier que de toute façon des masques
on a merdé on n'a pas assez de stock
donc on en a pas assez
les scandales les changements d'avis
tout d'un coup comme ça l'histoire des
matches ça a été un petit peu le
feuilleton du confinement donc on sait
plus trop à quoi s'en tenir
mais bon maintenant qu'on va tout s'en
mettre factuellement qu'est-ce qu'il
faut savoir avec les masques d'abord un
truc qui est vrai c'est que tout le
monde ait pas d'accord sur le sujet mais
quand même il ya beaucoup d'études
scientifiques qui se sont penchés sur la
question et qui démontre pas du tout que
ce soit efficace que tout le monde se
mette à porter des masques ça en gros il
ya trois raisons à ça la première raison
c'est que les masques vraiment efficace
ce qui empêche vraiment le virus de
passer à plus de 95 % y en a pas
beaucoup
va pas assez pour tout le monde donc
logique on les réserve pour les
soignants et pour les malades et les
autres faire nous on va porter des
masques en tissu ce qu'on appelle des
masques barrière qui sont beaucoup plus
faciles à se procurer
et beaucoup plus facile même à fabriquer
mais qui n'ont pas du tout du tout c'est
un euphémisme le même pouvoir filtrant
que les masques professionnel très
clairement
donc on va être moins bien protégés
après c'est quand même assez logique
les professionnels de santé ils sont
directement au contact de gens qui sont
à coup sûr
écoutez par le virus ce qui va pas être
notre cas donc c'est logique que hills
et les trucs les plus efficaces mais bon
on peut se dire raisonnablement que
quand même porter un masque
même si c'est pas le plus efficace c'est
quand même mieux que rien eba a priori
c'est plutôt vrai de se dire ça mais
seulement à deux conditions qui sont les
raisons numéro 2 et les raisons numéro 3
je sais pas si je vous ai perdu d'abord
il faut s'en servir correctement alors
faut pas forcément avoir fait médecine
pour y arriver
mais quand même il ya des règles à
respecter et par exemple si on se lave
pas bien les mains avant de le mettre ou
si on est toujours en train de tripoter
si on l'enlève qu'on leur met qu'on
passe à mende ce pour se gratter le nez
si on ne tripote etc
on risque de foot du virus dessus et
finalement ça risque d'être pire que si
on n'avait pas de masque parce qu'on
sait qu'on a plus facilement tendance à
tripoter quand on a un masque que quand
on n'a pas de masque et puis surtout le
principal risque c'est de se sentir bien
protégé parce qu'on a un masque et du
coup d'être un petit peu moins attentifs
à tous les autres gestes barrière alors
que nous vraiment pas du tout il faut
considérer que le masque c'est un moyen
supplémentaire
georgette barrière supplémentaire mais
que les seuls qui ont vraiment fait la
preuve de leur efficacité
scientifiquement c'est les gestes
barrières qu'on connaît déjà tous et qui
va falloir continuer à appliquer à la
lettre et même encore plus que quand on
était tous enfermés chez nous donc en
plus de toutes les mesures générales
c'est à dire certains lieux qui vont
rester fermés des manifestations qui
vont pas reprendre tout de suite le
télétravail qui va quand même falloir
continuer à mettre en place à chaque
fois que c'est possible et c'est il va
ya voir ces fameux gestes barrières
qu'il va falloir continuer à respecter
maintenant tout le monde les connaît
mais je les rappelle quand même ce tous
ces essais éternuer dans le coude se
servir d'un mouchoir à usage unique et
le jeter quand on aura fini quand on
n'en a plus besoin respecter une
distance de un mètre minimum entre
chaque personne est donc évidemment pas
se faire la bise pas se serrer la main
passe au pied ou je sais pas quoi et se
laver les mains le plus régulièrement
possible ou se passer du gel
hydroalcoolique si on peut pas se laver
les mains
voilà vous connaissez mes
à petit truc petit aparté au sujet des
mains les gants vraiment pour le coup ça
sert à rien que vous touchiez un truc
avec votre peau ou avec du latex
c'est la même qui vous touchez un truc
plein de virus et que soit vous touchez
autre chose après vous ne contamine et
si vous touchez un truc plein de virus
et que vous portez la main au visage
bah vous vous contaminer que vous ayez
des gants ou pas donc le seul truc c'est
vous laver les mains régulièrement et
vous évitez de porter la main au visage
basta dgo et puis dernier truc il reste
la question des tests alors par rapport
à tout ce qu'on a vu sur l'immunité
le fait que l'on n'est pas sûr que les
anticorps protège vraiment qu'on sait
pas combien de temps et sait faire des
tests sérologiques à tout le monde ça a
été envisagé un moment finalement ça
sert pas à grand chose donc on va faire
autrement à partir du 11 mai vu que
maintenant
a priori il y en a assez on va pouvoir
faire des tests à tous les gens qui ont
des symptômes des tests pour savoir
s'ils ont le virus ou pas si ils ont le
virus
ils sont en isolement en quarantaine
pendant 14 jours
et puis on va rechercher tous les gens
avec qui ils ont été en contact et
l'appareil des tests pour tout le monde
et quarantaine pour tous les gens qui
sont positifs il va rester
le problème de savoir comment on va
trouver ces gens c'est pas encore réglé
il ya cette histoire d'applications etc
pour l'instant c'est pas mais j'ai comme
l'impression qu'on va en reparler assez
rapidement ou alors juste un truc de la
même façon que au moment du confinement
il a fallu attendre quelques semaines
pour voir si ça fonctionnait bien là au
moment du déclenchement il va falloir
attendre quelques semaines deux semaines
minimum minimum pour voir s'il ya pas
une reprise de l'épidémie
donc ça va pas savoir ça tout de suite
mais en attendant ce qu'il va falloir
faire c'est qu'il va falloir se dire
deux ou trois trucs
déjà il faut pas raisonner en termes de
est ce que j'ai le droit est ce que j'ai
pas le droit est ce que c'est bien
est-ce que c'est pas bien
l'idée c'est juste qu'il faut limiter au
maximum la circulation du virus donc il
faut limiter les contacts et en tout cas
respecter au maximum la distanciation
physique
la manne ensuite il faut arrêter de
penser que les gestes barrières et
toutes les précautions c'est fait pour
se protéger soi c'est un peu vrai mais
il faut se dire que c'est surtout fait
pour protéger les autres si par hasard
on est malade et qu'on ne sait pas et
qu'on a pas de signe par exemple c'est
important de se dire ça juste un petit
exemple quand vous allez faire vos
courses
lavez vous les mains avant de sortir de
chez vous un pas seulement quand vous
rentrez des courses voilà après les
gestes barrière dont on vient de leur
parler là il faut bien se dire qu'il va
falloir être encore plus vigilant encore
plus carrée que quand on était confiné
parce que là mathématiquement et avoir
plus de contacts dont il ya plus de
risque de choper le virus et de le
transmettre
donc on relâche pas l'attention là
dessus il faut être encore plus attentif
gabon et fille dernier truc il va
falloir être un petit peu patient parce
que ben on a tous bien compris que ça na
pas reprendre comme avons là comme ça
tout de suite
alors j'ai fait un petit sondage sur
twitter manifestement les trucs que vous
attendez le plus là c'est revoir vos
familles vos potes vos mecs comme neuf
c'est avoir des rapports sexuels
c'est faire la fête faire des bonnes
bouffes aller boire des coups dans des
bars éventuellement c'est aussi aller
faire un tour à la campagne est allé
chez le coiffeur vraiment très
globalement c'est les trucs que vous
attendez le plus avec le des continents
alors il ya des trucs qu'on va pouvoir
faire tout de suite mais il va falloir
s'adapter
un petit peu et puis il ya des trucs ça
va pas être pour tout de suite tout de
suite pas on va pas retourner bouffer au
resto boire des coups au bistrot en
terrasse et c'est avec les potes tout de
suite
a priori ce sera pas avant début juin
si enfin mail on estime que le nombre de
cas est satisfaisant mais les grosses
bouffes où les grosses soirées chez vous
dans votre appart parce que je sais que
vous y avez pensé c'est pas pour tout de
suite non plus parce que pour l'instant
les rassemblements qu'ils soient publics
ou privés c'est maximum dix personnes
donc organiser un apéro chez soi
pourquoi pas mais à un mètre de distance
les uns des autres et à moins de 10
personnes
après je sais pas comment est votre
salon à vous
on voit très clairement un mètre de
distance comme ça chez moi on tient pas
a dit les trains pour aller faire un
petit tour à la campagne ça peut être
tout de suite non plus là on peut
changer de département uniquement pour
motifs professionnels ou familiaux
impérieux on sait pas trop ce que ça
veut dire mais très clairement aller
faire une petite balade en forêt ça ne
rentre pas dans ce cas le programme
festif
pour ce qui est des rapports sexuels bon
alors à un mètre de distance avec un
masque pourquoi pas un par contre
attention le gel hydroalcoolique ça peut
piquer un petit peu bon en vrai pour les
rapports sexuels c'est vous qui voyez je
ne suis pas votre mère et je suis pas eu
l'heur philippe le coiffeur par contre
bonne nouvelle ça va être bon dès le 11
mai est a priori un
par contre je vous conseille d'être vif
parce que a priori vous n'êtes pas les
seuls sur le coup oui je veille à moi
par exemple je considère que je suis une
engeance donc
qu'avez-vous donc il va falloir être
patient ça c'est vrai mais on va essayer
de voir les choses du bon côté
imaginons scénario idéal on gère nickel
et du coup on peut lever les
restrictions et les mesures de
protection au fur et à mesure au début
on risque d'avoir un petit peu de mal à
s'y remettre
déjà on brise le flipper un peu de tout
le monde et puis on est plus habitué
donc on ne risque pas savoir comment se
comporter vous êtes un petit peu empoté
dans nos relations sociales
on risque d'être un petit peu ankylosé
si vous voulez donc c'est pas plus mal
que les choses reviennent
progressivement pour qu'on ait le temps
de se réhabituer quelqu'un qui a fait
une grève de la faim on l'envoie pas
directement au buffet à volonté parce
que sinon c'est la catastrophe assurée
bon bah là c'est pareil
dieu en plus si on veut être un petit
peu philosophe ça va être encore mieux
de récupérer des petites if jour après
jour semaine après semaine comme ça au
début ça va être juste sortir ouf
aller se balader
plus loin que son quartier voir des gens
voir des potes déjà dans un premier
temps ça va être génial
et puis après ça va être pouvoir
retourner dans un bar à lait se refaire
un petit resto à les refaire un ciné
vous imaginez et puis après encore ça va
être retournée à la salle de sport parce
que ça pour l'instant ça va pas être
possible non plus et puis encore après
peut-être qu'on leur a même le droit de
retourner à la plage peut-être même
qu'on va avoir des vacances ça va aller
crescendo ça va être ça va être chouette
non de toute façon on va se dire que
peint on n'a pas le choix et que deux en
faisant ça comme on le fait depuis le
début on sauve des vies
donc prenons notre mal en patience
soyons à soyaux philosophe voit la dtcc
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici
là prenez soin de vous mais surtout
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]